hello everyone some of you may not know
this but from 16 to 29th of March the
European individual championship was
being held and since it was coming in
the same time as the as the 2018
candidates tournament everywhere
everyone was pretty much following the
2018 candidates tournament but the
European individual championship is a
pretty big deal so here is a game by the
winner of the European Championship 2018
even charged I've already shown you one
game played by Charlotte I believe it
was a game in round five also against
the Croatian Grandmaster madam Basia - I
will put a link to that game in the
description below
it's a very nice miniature against the
Sicilian in that video I already
mentioned that even charge is a multiple
time creation champion he's a he's a
World Junior World Champion and in 2014
he won the Tata Steel challengers
tournament qualified for the toughest
two masters in 2015 and in 2014 chess
olympiad he defeated Magnus Carlsen so a
lot of a lot of great things for him in
charge and he now here now if you want
the 2018 European Championship it's 12
years after another Croatian
grandmasters Denko coach will also want
it in 2006 so let's see this game he has
the white pieces against ego tiyanak
polish Polish freedom master ready I
believe around 24 24 20 somewhere around
20 for 20 I don't know if I mentioned
the championship is being held in Batumi
in Georgia and the prize fund for the
entire tournament is 100 thousand euros
first place being 20,000 euros so even
charged 120 thousand euros and not only
that he also qualified for the World Cup
so not only him but 20 at 22 of the
highest place
contestants also placed for the world a
qualified for the World Cup so who knows
in in the next the candidates tournament
we might we might be even seeing even
charge if he does it really well
the next World Cup so let's see this
game and it's quite an interesting game
especially if you're a Korell con player
or if you enjoy playing against the
caro-kann efore by even charvak c6 the
caro-kann d4 d5 and now ii 5 the
advanced variation Bishop to a5 and now
not G for the everyone's favorite
bayonets but rather Knight to f3 Knight
to f3 this is the short variation of the
advanced korok on e6 Bishop to e2 and
Knight to d7 white castles and now h6
now black is already showing that he
will go Queen c7 Castle queenside and
then start his expansion on the on the
King side as a white already castled
Knight B to d2 not going Knight to c3 as
black will Castle queenside white will
want to push C 3 B 4 a 4 and start his
own expansion on the Queen side 97 C 3
now Queen to c7 B 4 and now g5 Knight to
b3
Bishop to g7 and mountain Knights the e1
removing this Knight 2 D 3 our it will
maybe maybe in the future come to c5 or
or it will support the advance of the f4
pawn and here black decides to do a move
that's not really sacrifice as he pretty
much immediately gets material
compensation for it he plays it Knight
captures on e5 of course you do have to
capture it pawn captures and now Bishop
captures this comes with a double attack
on the c3 pawn and also on the h2 pawn
so here Knight the d4 was played
allowing captures on h2 this is the
correct idea King to h1 and now Bishop
back to Bishop back to d6 so black
already want his three points for the
piece so not really not really a
sacrifice but it's interesting could you
could you maybe allow this bishop to get
trapped for example let's just see what
happens if it gets trapped with a move
like g3 for example the thing is white
will not play gt-r immediately first
white will grab another piece and after
he captures only then play g3 and after
you play Bishop captures pawn captures
and Queen captures you don't have a lot
of points here and the night but
but white is perfectly safe here after
he attacked wing Queen checks King moves
now comes g4 rook captures and after for
example g3 threatening threatening Queen
to h2 and now you will have worked to h5
and the black doesn't have any any more
steam to continue this attack so after
King to h1 Mishra back to d6 not
allowing the bishop to get trapped and
now of course Knight captures on f5
Knight captures and now Bishop to d3
Knight to g7 and not allowing this
bishop to capture the night also f5 will
be an idea in the future C for D
captures on c4 Bishop captures on c4 and
now a queenside castle Queen to e2
getting the Queen out of the way
also maybe maybe Bishop captures and e6
will be an idea in the future g4 and
here Bishop to b2 the idea of white
black plays g4 is it's pretty simple he
wants to open lights towards the attack
against the white king but there's even
an immediate threat if you captured its
Bishop to e5 simply attacking the
undefended rook on an a1 and if you move
the rook then the bishop is now
defending the d4 square then rook to d4
is coming would attempt on the Queen and
now black black mobilized all of his
pieces rather quickly
also the bishop when it comes to e5 is
guarding the knight and g7 so black now
gets more than compensation for the
piece so after g4 first Bishop to b2 not
allowing Bishop to e5 and now rook H to
g8 again offering the g4 pawn but now
charge takes it as he calculates it
precisely Knight to a5 opening up an
attack against the Queen Queen to h3 and
now Bishop to e5 Bishop captures Queen
characters and now Knight to f3
attacking the Queen Queen to c3 and now
rook F the c1
defending the bishop the Queen has to
move Queen capture some before and now
rook a to b 1 so both Brookes are now
developed we have Queen to d6 and now
rook the c3 the rook will be very useful
here helping out with the defense of the
King side also he can always transfer it
to b3 and then have doubled the rooks on
the B file
a lot a lot of good ideas for this rook
when it comes to c3 so a nice rook lift
h5 by black and now King to g1 kink the
g1 with the idea
white would like to capture on h5 then
on f7 and then maybe all the way to b7
who knows these are open there's these
are lines that are waiting to be opened
so why not why not make a threat here so
King to g1 you don't want to capture it
and then allow something like rook to h8
here look to h8 now defending the pawn
and now Knight to g5 good ideas of knife
captures on f7 with this beautiful fork
Queen to e7 defending yet also attacking
the knight and g5 and now Knight to e4
route to d4 and now white White has a
winning position here and ok when I when
I saw this rook move I thought Knight to
c6 simply what ideas of it attacking the
pawn here of course you can't capture
because but captures wins the Queen so I
thought after we play this b6 and then
something something I have no idea and
I'm not not at I've seen it
Knight to b3 and then you have to see
ideas after rook captures on h4 what to
do here but instead of deciding what to
do there sharra immediately played the
strongest move Bishop to a6 and now now
you really do have some some problems if
you play pawn captures on a6 then you
get a row capture c6 will check King to
d7 and now you can either go for some
checkmating ideas with Queen to c3 but
even the barbaric rook to b7 check is
sufficient to win the game but after
this Bishop h6 egoriy onic played rook
captures on e4
but now comes Rock captures on c6 Bishop
captures on b7 is also an idea about
rook captures on c6 forces the game to
end more more quickly King to d8 and now
we have Queen to c3 and after Queen to
c3 polish freedom master ego Yannick
resigned to the game this is a game from
this is a game I believe from round one
maybe even of the tournament
but it's a very nice game only 33 moves
and I spinach or so I thought you you
would enjoy this one but yeah there are
simply too many threats rook to see it
is a threat if you capture it then the
other rook can come to b8 the queen is
also attacking the rook on h8 so simply
too many threats here the most obvious
if you capture it and simply Queen
captures on h8 now if you block then
again rook to b8 wins if you move the
king and anywhere doesn't really matter
see 77 then this rope is finally coming
to be 7 and then then black black and
simply resign but yeah after Queen to c3
black resigned the game and a nice
victory for creation grandmaster even
charged and now the the official
European chess champion for 2018 and I
did prepare some results to include here
as you can see only one with eight and a
half points even charged and then with
eight points there are actually there
are actually seven people tied Maxima
Telecom el Tasha Farley Sun and Surigao
Gawain Jones
Anton core above Arado Slovakia Czech
and Luke McShane and a lot of strong
players to follow so definitely a strong
competition and there were as you can
see on the bottom of the page there were
three hundred and four players in total
so an excellent tournament and an
excellent results for the Croatian
Grandmaster even charged so like I said
this qualifies him along with 2021 other
players for the for the next World Cup
where everyone will get their chance
maybe win a seat at the candidates
tournament and maybe face whoever will
be world champion than either cousin or
Caruana so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Greta Roddy Southgate and the me
tune rush for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
probably with a nice tall versus botany
game thank you all and see you soon